bonjour à tout le monde merci décès de
moi un mouton disait le petit prince
vous en souvenez peut-être de l'histoire
et la réplique du pilote qui s'était
fait la réflexion intérieure en dix ans
j'avais été découragés dans ma carrière
de peintre par les grandes personnes à
l'âge de six ans et je n'avais jamais
appris à dessiner
sauf des bois ouvert les baux à ferme et
souvenir de ça peut-être un peu
quelqu'un vous est il déjà proposé de
dessiner votre école de rêve une école
que vous aurez vraiment voulu avoir vos
propres enfants une école que vous allez
peut-être même voulu fréquenté lorsque
vous étiez petit depuis 150 ans on se
concentre montrer à lire à écrire et à
calculer à enseigner les réformes se
succèdent aux dix ou quinze ans
approximativement partout pour améliorer
les résultats académiques
on se concentre là-dessus principalement
mais les réformes en ont deux
caractéristiques assez particulière
c'est que première chose
le premier relais première des choses
c'est qu'elles sont imaginés par des
instances des au système éducatif bien à
l'extérieur des écoles et le deuxième
élément c'est qu'elles sont imposées aux
écoles aux directions d'école aux
enseignants je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui d'une école qui me passionne
une école qui manie sion de vie l'école
communautaire entrepreneuriale
consciente une école bien différent une
école où on propose au fond que les
jeunes puissent entreprendre pour que
les jeunes puissent apprendre
s'entreprendre apprendre à entre on
apprendre à créer de l'innovation a créé
ligne de l'innovation pour apprendre en
fin de compte à sortir des sentiers
battus à trouver des solutions nouvelles
à imaginer peut-être ce qui n'a pu même
pas encore été imaginées une école très
différente en
199 on me confie une école en fait on me
confie deux écoles deux écoles dont une
des écoles avaient un indice
socio-économique de 8 sur 10 sauvaître
sur 10 à 10 c'est le niveau le plus le
plus élevé de la pauvreté dans un milieu
socio éducatif pour ceux qui connaissent
et bien dans cette école les choses il y
avait des défis importants les défis
multiples le décrochage pédagogique par
exemple des enfants qui étaient
décrochés des méthodes traditionnelles
l'enseignement il ya le décrochage
pédagogique on peut parler du décrochage
éducatif ça voudrait dire qu'à ce moment
là qu'on décroche des contenus c'est la
dynamique de l'échec qui arrive
pire c'est le décrochage scolaire à ce
moment là c'est l'abandon
c'est la non diplomation et on sait ce
que ça veut dire on a vu des résultats
assez inquiétants publiés au québec ne
publie aussi ailleurs il n'y a pas
qu'elle québec
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on est peut-être
devant une crise mondiale de l'éducation
on est certainement à mon avis dans une
crise mondiale de l'éducation
il n'y a pas qu'au québec on se pose des
questions partout dans le monde on se
dit qu'il faut que les choses changent
il faut que l'école change mais et on
propose bien des choses mais pas souvent
on arrive à vraiment créer une nouvelle
école à bâtir une nouvelle école est
peut-être parce que justement on a
peut-être oublié quelque chose de
fondamental qui serait de refaire rêver
les enseignants font rêver toute une
communauté
les faire rêver les années de 20 un
dessin afin à dessiner leur école d'art
f
imaginez imaginez sont parvenus à le
faire un jour dans notre école
on était devant des défis tellement
grand et on savait tellement que seul on
est impossible d'y répondre seul est
impossible de répondre à tous les défis
de de décrochage ou défi de délinquance
ou phénomènes de délinquance comme par
exemple le tabac gesu dé la drogue même
à l'école même où prime 1
mais mon primaire on était devant des
défis qui faisait que dans l'école où on
venait de me confier les gens disaient
que c'était l'école à éviter sur le
territoire
cette école là on l'évité c'était même
difficile de trouver des enseignants
pour venir et y enseigner parfois c'est
à dire il nous fallait super c'était pas
évident
le défi était entier et devant tous et
ses éléments à l'appui une des choses
que je voudrais faire remarquer aussi à
chaque année on avait un autre problème
assez important c'est que il y avait une
chute continue de la clientèle scolaire
c'est-à-dire une chute continue du
nombre d'inscrits à l'école c'est un
phénomène de décroissance parce que
drastiques
vous savez que dans les années qu'elle
essuie trop quatre ans plus tard
peut-être que l'école allait peut-être
fermer c'est pas le risque est tel en
tous les cas le risque était réellement
là alors aussi mis à travailler ensemble
ensemble retenir le mot consent à
dessiner notre école de rêve pour
répondre à ces besoins là qu'étaient nos
besoins à nous les besoins de cette
école les besoins de nos élèves et avec
les enseignants
peu à peu on a fini par développer un
programme qu'on a plus un programme
d'apprentissage en entrepreneuriat
conscient on venait de créer le coeur et
l'âme d'une école communautaire
entrepreneuriale conscient un programme
qui va avoir quatre volets je voulais
nomme du sport à culture entrepreneuriat
sa pièce 5 entreprenariale s vous l'a
dit on a fait ce port de santés imaginez
demain matin une société productif sans
la santé et tous les défis liés à la
santé
c'est important les arts commun vous
savez on rende à des entreprises vont
rapidement devoir c'est attirant de
rappeler dans une entreprise lorsque
lorsqu'elle est belle lorsqu'il les
choses sont bien mis les ans permet de
créer la beauté et chez les jeunes
parfois on a l'impression que que ça
s'est un peu abandonnés oubliés dans les
écoles la culture on y 7 milliards sur
un an
pioneer qui aujourd'hui on a besoin
comme jamais d'apprendre à partager les
ressources qui restent comme jamais non
conscient en fait pourquoi parce que
c'était le fil conducteur pédagogique et
éducatif de toute l'école en
entrepreneuriat comme disait je cite et
rabelais qui disait nous en souvenez
peut-être science sans conscience n'est
que ruine de l'âme
dans cette optique là aussi mis à faire
de l'entrepreneuriat conscient à l'école
à tout égard on marchait et au fait la
mesure au fur et à mesure que je
marchais dans l'école au fil des
semaines des mois des années on voyait
des projets un peu partout apparaître
des projets fabuleux des enfants heureux
qui souriaient parce qu'on leur faisait
confiance parce qu'on leur donnait le
droit à s'exprimer dans cette école là
il y avait un lien comme les autres
d'ailleurs on venait de partout pour la
visite et plus de 17 délégations
d'autant de pays à travers le monde
viendront la visiter ce une période de
trois ans alors laissez-moi vous décrire
un tout petit peu ce qu'on pouvait voir
dans cette école par exemple en marchant
juste là dans une classe de 6ème 1ère
2ème année on pouvait apercevoir une
maison d'édition à l'école où les
enfants
imaginez devenait l'auteur de leur
propre livre
écrire son livre illustré son livre
publié son attention avec le quatrième
de couverture
oui la photo de l'auteur la biographie
c'est sérieux c'est très sérieux
imaginez maman qui papa arrivent à
l'école des grands-parents voix s'y
livrent là qui avait été fait par
l'enfant lui-même
vous comprenez là qu'on peut apprendre
le français autrement que par des
méthodes traditionnelles
c'en est un exemple en maths par exemple
jour il ya plus d face à l'école sa
fondue un petit peu peut-être que ça a
été rangé ses patrons et les crayons
aussi
l'enseignant un autre défi c'est qu'elle
veut leur faire apprendre les
mathématiques leur apprendre à compter
par bon 5 10 15 concept d'unité dizaines
de centaines soustraire additionner les
enfants aux 7,1 et halo l'idée de créer
un magasin scolaire mais elle ne dit pas
aux enfants
elle anime la classe et elle fait surgir
différents noms qu'on pourrait bien
donner à cette micro-entreprise à cette
nouvelle ni coentreprise pédagogie alors
plusieurs noms sont donnés et puis un
moment donné on a faim dit c'était pas
le plus fort l'académisme mais il a eu
une idée géniale idée bureau un petit
plat
l'enseignante peu déconcerté le
trouvaient malgré son petit peu trop
commercial un bon monsieur caron que je
connaissais bien qu'attaché bureau en
gros est à content mais bon mais voyez
ils ont elles à cette idée là il crée
duranti elle va aller très loin dans des
concepts mathématiques inimaginable elle
crée l ordi bris mais là il faut acheter
les les artic scola il faut décider ce
qu'on va acheter puis combien on reste
collé avec à la fin d'année vous
imaginez l aide essaie de leur faire
faire une étude de marché incertain
pour appliquer un concept de
mathématiques l'histogramme qu'on
apprend plutôt secondaire vous en
conviendrez
et là ils l'ont fait chez des petits de
7 1 un peu plus loin dans l'école un
après midi les choses vos mains les
enseignantes avaient donné le droit des
jeunes d'année leur jouet favori c'est
une activité récompense l'école et huit
sur dix est la pauvreté
il ya des amis qui qui n'ont pas du tout
jouer cet après midi là une animation et
fait parce qu'on est dans une école
communautaire entrepreneuriale
conscience émerge une idée formidable
mais les enfants décident mais pourquoi
pas dans ce colloque pour les amis qui
n'ont pas de jouer pourquoi pas faire
une bibliothèque de jouer on pourrait
louer les joies comme à la bibliothèque
il imagine ajouté mais dans la pédagogie
qu'on avance et enfants jouent trois au
rôle extraordinaire et enfin son
initiateur ils sont à réalisateur ils
sont en tout gestionnaire prend des
décisions quand des risques planifiée et
coordonnée conceptualiser ils font tout
ça ils se décident dont date les oeufs
alors je vous dis tu es coffre à jouets
incorporez aujourd'hui vous allez voir
sur le site internet on peut voir la
petite vidéo qui fabuleuse parce qu'ils
vont gagner le grand prix national
d'entrepreneuriat vous savez oui le
grand prix national d'entrepreneurs et
gagner avec cette entreprise
entrepreneuriat social cette fois-ci
solidaire un entrepreneuriat
communautaire est doté d'autres jeux
comme ça vaut prendre forme à
l'intérieur de l'école un jour arrive
une situation qui fait que et bien sûr
l'école avait changé nous n'étions plus
de 20 la même école tout avait changé
tout était transformé j'avais et on
cherchait désespérément depuis un an et
demi un nouveau nom pour l'écolo non qui
la représentent très voilà que à ce
moment là un matin j'arrive à l'école
une enseignante me dit j'ai été réveillé
à 4 heures ce matin dans la nuit et
j'étais réveillé quelque chose qui m'est
venue à l'esprit il faut qu'il faut que
10 j'ai un nom que je crois avoir trouvé
pour l'école de bons et mehdi écoles
coeur vaillant
soudainement je suis envahi par une
émotion incroyable je m'en vais dans mon
bureau je peux pas dire un mot en
revenant je reviens je lui dis tu sais
j'aime beaucoup sa récolte la vaillance
et qu'en fait elle m'avait ramené dans
mon enfance
quant à mon entourage à moi mon père mes
oncles dans mon petit village natal
l'acadie du nouveau brunswick me disait
tu sais mon garçon quant à du corps et
qui était vaillant dans la vie tu vas
loin et pour moi ça veut incarner toute
l'école qu'on voulait des petits coeurs
vaillants par tous les enfants les
adultes les partenaires de la communauté
un village unifiée main à la main pour
changer les choses pour changer le monde
et c'est skinheads se passer là
tellement que l'intérêt et la curiosité
du monde est inouï on se met en voix je
le disais tu l'as dit visite de partout
dans le monde des gens qui s'intéressent
aux modèles et ça nous amène à une
création formidable un rêve que j'avais
c'était de dire est ce qu'on pourrait
pas permet à des enfants d'ailleurs à
des enfants de mon pas de ma propre
province à des enfants ailleurs au
québec et des enfants ailleurs au canada
et dans le monde de profiter de cette
éducation là et on l'a fait aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des écoles la province de
north of the way s'inspire de ce modèle
au tant au primaire qu'au secondaire
aujourd'hui on est dans le 25 30 écoles
au québec déjà des écoles primaires
secondaires et désormais dans un centre
de formation professionnelle
le modèle de rendre l'enfant le jeune de
jeunes adultes initiateurs isat heures
et gestionnaires de devenir compétences
entre trains entre temps qu'à
l'innovation fait son chemin et surtout
l'organisation qu'on propose
et on a créé l'organisation
internationale des écoles communautaires
entreprenariale conscience grâce un
leader formidable la commission scolaire
marguerite bourgeoys de montréal une
commission scolaire visionnaire et
audacieuse qui a osé
nous avons environ 2005 je reste parce
que des fois on se dit pourquoi
l'entrepreneuriat conscient mais
pourquoi l'entrepreneuriat concert il ya
une histoire fabuleuse qui s'est passé à
mon école on est au début septembre une
enseignante c'est que l'année soit
difficile plusieurs élèves ont des
difficultés la moitié de la classe au
moins des dossiers comme on dit les
enfants qui ont des difficultés
multiples et à ce moment là elle décide
de lancer une chorale pour qu'ils
apprennent l'entreprise soit à se faire
confiance à ces nids h valoriser des
jeunes qui n'avaient pas eu facile des
fonds dit quand tu pars avec deux prises
contre toi au départ c'était le cas
j'aimerais vous faire en temps à
l'instant ce que j'ai entendu lorsque je
lis dans cette classe et j'ai dû
m'asseoir pour demander aux enfants
pouvez vous s'il vous plaît me la jouer
non
amore
cette chorale a fait vibrer l'école et
s'est mis à chanter dans la communauté
en ville à québec des avants spectacle
par les harmonies faisait venir jusqu'à
la salle albert rousseau
cette chorale là que vous voulez le voir
ils l'ont fait les enfants qui pourtant
avait pâti l'année avec mais vous savez
ils ont réussi leur année ils ont tous
réussi dans l'année le rennais et
échanger et leur vie a été changé 17
enfin sur 21 c'est à sa classe de 3e
année que vous allez voir pas
sélectionné dans l'école 17 ans en ce 21
avait la voix imaginez le petit mira il
cette enseignante nous cache un secret
formidable son secret il était maître de
chorale et on l'avait appris grâce au
fait que cette école autorisait que les
enfants puissent choisir ce qu'ils
aiment de temps en temps que les
enseignants puissent offrir ce qui les
passionne et que tout le village
participe de manière organisée et
structurée de temps en temps aussi de
manière organisée cv l'entrepreneuriat
contient aussi parce que on est devant
cette folle et terrifiante impression
une compagnie sans scrupules va bientôt
peut-être sorti le dernier mini raz du
sol qu'une autre a coupé le dernier
râble que quelqu'un quelque part
le bateau usine peut-être va pêcher ou
volé le dernier poisson mais il ya de
l'espoir et ce sont les enfants et je
voudrais vous l'effet qu'une parole
d'enfant qui était très très heureux
d'avoir réussi son primat et qu'on lui
demandait si elle ne craignait pas aller
où se vendent à voici sa réponse à la
fin de son cycle de 6e année
je sais que je suis capable de réussir
ça que je vais ensuite cloud
merci à tous